I've written down the first line it's
the easy life right
the part that follows is a bit trickier
it's the thing that makes completing the
square
completing the square but I sort of left
your little put on your own this was
easy because we already knew what we
expected the question is what do I add
to both sides here that will give me
like I have here a perfect square on the
left okay what number do I have okay
then help me recognize what number you
add I'm gonna call you back own it's
examples we did it before right B then
there's an X plus 3 here right this 3
get leaders toward this number and this
number right you see that how does the 3
turn to the 6 you double it right you
double it that's how three becomes six
how does it three turn into the nine the
answer is you square it right if I gave
you another example for instance this
guy X plus five all squared and I asked
you to expand that expand these
generally easier than Rosie
it's going to give you this 10x plus 25
you see again that five the five it
turns into the ten by doubling and it
turns into the 25 by squaring right okay
now what are we trying to do we're
trying to go not from this number to
each of those numbers we're trying to go
from this one we've got that one there
he is - 12 we're trying to go from him
to here right so right now you told me
to go from three to six you double so
how do you go from six to three you the
opposite of doubling is Harvey let you
harm it you / - okay so to go from six
to three you have it and then you go
from three to nine you square it let me
test that again so you're from ten to
five I have it and then you go from five
to twenty five I square it that's the
two things I do that complete the square
I have then I squared Phi that's so
important I'm gonna write it I have
I swear okay
Harvard Square that's a bit funny wrap
it around but watch how it works -
twelve would you have it for me
c- six but when I swear it it won't
matter right six then I square it that
gives me 36 so I'm gonna add a 36 to
both sides now I have a square right
this guy over here I can factor right
I'm gonna use that same step that you
told me to work out the factorization
you always gonna get that X out the
front right but when you hunt it that's
where you got this intermediate number
right which is squared to get the 36
right you see that so hardly and it's
squaring that's what gives you this
number
but Harmon just gives you that one from
done what do I get on the right hand
side 16 which conveniently is a square
number because these you've already
worked out there were no weird
irrational thirds or anything up what do
i do from here I was at this point right
now I take the square root so I'm quite
Thanks - seeks the square root of 16 is
4 but I don't just have plus 4 I have
minus 4 as well okay and the last thing
to get the X by itself is I add 6 to
both sides okay now here are the two
solutions but I can do some simplifying
here right one of them is minus 4 and
the other one is plus 4 okay but you
already knew this didn't you we solve
this we saw this just before we got
these same solutions so this method is
always going to work right we didn't
need it for this question but you do
need it for some all right okay last one
again we're going to take a question
we've already done so we know what the
answers are but because it's not Manik
you have to add one extra step in which
makes things look a little Messier but
it'll be fun okay so be that it's not
money
I need to make it Manik all of these
questions with complete list
they needed to have just a single x
squared at the front so being that I've
got eight of them what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna divide every single term by
eight I'm going to divide this one by
eight and this one and this one and this
one
hey you've got to divide everything 8x
squared divided by eight it's just x
squared minus two x over eight I can do
some canceling they're just a little bit
that's minus 1/4 X you okay with that
I can't really do anything to that
monster you ever read can i he just kind
of pointed around there and 0 over a is
still 0 okay so this looks a little
worse because it's got fractions but
that's okay we can still handle this
right I want to get a square over here
that minus 3 over 8 is in the way so
we're gonna kick it over the other side
x squared
my name is support X and that'll leave
me with three eighths on the right hand
side and now here comes my completing
step right how did I add this number
what did i do again I have then I
squared
kharbut a little square so half of this
half of a quarter here's a quarter right
there's a quarter over there so half of
that is this guy that's that's an eight
right it's even smaller so I'm going to
add an eighth square right and eight
square now for reasons that will become
clear in a second I'm just going to
write that without picking out what it
is okay I'll work out what is it a
second I've added to the left so I
better add it to the right dad okay
after now the reason why I was so lazy
over here in just writing an eight
squared I'm not writing 1 over 64 which
is what it is is that over here I'm just
going to use that 8 right this is going
to be X minus that number okay you can
see if I went back here right you would
double 1 over 8 which would give you 1/4
and then you would square it and it
would give
and it sweat all right
now on the right hand side I'll deal
with this guy this is whatever 64 right
1 over 64
I've got fractures here I know you can
do this on your calculator but the more
you use your brain to take advantage of
the fact that you can do things like
this the stronger it gets
okay so if 3 over 8 if I want to add
that to something over 64 how am I gonna
make this common denominator I'm gonna
have to multiply by 8 right today the
denominator 64 which makes the numerator
three times eight which is 24 okay both
over 64 what's 24 plus 125
okay I'm almost there I'm so very close
I'm officious and then you can head off
right
what step in my up - I've got a square
on the left hand side how do I get rid
of it take the square root right so I
get that the squares gone I get a plus
or minus on the right hand side 25 is a
squared over what's the square root 5
and 64 squared oh I know that I got it
my Sperry it gives me 8 so now I put
that 1 8 over the other side and there
are my two solutions let me just make it
clear he's the -1 and he is the plus one
and eight minus five eighths that's -
how many eighths 1 minus 5 that's 4 - 4
8 is minus 1/2
does that look familiar or one side
tonight 1 plus 5 that's 6/8 6 beds you
can simplify that that's three quarters
Julia